on en parle souvent mais est-ce que
poutine il a un un mec qui est très très
très proche de lui qui peut le conquis
le conseil qui lui dit des choses et qui
peut lui dire des choses ou est ce que
il n'a vraiment pas un bras droit comme
tout le monde arbres à noix vous avez un
brin de matthieu delormeau ses goûts
valérie bénaïm cesser son chien
non mais est ce que parce que ça c'est
vrai c'est qui avant il y en avait et il
en avait donné sa femme vous nous aviez
déjà sa femme bon et que sa femme l'a
quitté donc du coup parce que pourquoi
sa femme parce que sa femme le tutoie le
connais depuis toujours bien sûr c'est
la seule personne qui pouvait lui dire
on va tu fais des conneries elles ont
cassé dans les yeux l oncav cfia poutou
24 27 24 et 27 c sahel
elle parle pas leur belle peuvent pas
dire à leurs pairs elle est si vous
savez jamais
dit jamais ce que ce soit d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs cia il se dit patriote oui
ses deux filles habitent à l'étranger
dans un pays européen où sa hollande
d'accord pour l'une et bill gariche
comme pour l'autre donc déjà qu'ils ont
quitté leur usine ils s'en fichent de
leur pays ils profitent le ministre des
affaires étrangères lavrov pareil sa
fille a fait des études aux états unis
élevée aux etats unis et si vous prenez
la moitié des ministres ils ont toute
leur famille en occident et après ils
vont dire l'occident c'est notre ennemi
on me croit lutte contre le temps mais
on préfère venir ski à courchevel
acheter des nice
côte d'azur tout l'as monaco ça c'est
des traditions en grand
sous les gardons bien sûr
il n'a plus personne pour vous il a
évidemment bras droit disons que petit à
petit il ya quoi medvedev d en qualité
président qui tire un peu la magie les
militants entendent et des trucs parce
qu'en fait elle a été varié il a été
évincé
et donc de tenter il publie quelque
chose mais c'est des conneries mais il
est déçu parce que l'été il n'était pas
de le doigt le bras droit il était là la
marionnette c'est ton à la marque a
développé un peu de son arc c'était un
acteur parce qu'en fait poutine ne
pouvait pas être élu il a mis medvedev
le temps qu'ils ont c'est comme si on
mettait une poupée bao medvedeva cette
poupée donc et donc il a personne qui
lui parle il n'ya pas de mal il ya plus
de doha doit désarmer il a pas un mec
génial un truc qui lui dit disons qu il
ya des gens bien évidemment il ya le
ministre de la défense il ya le chef
d'état-major donc tous eu tous ces gens
là viennent le voir il ya les chefs de
renseignement militaires y aller mais
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé avec le
chef de renseignements narychkine a dit
mon bar à côté mathieu alba
raconté donc il y avait une réunion le
21 février et là il a réuni tout son
staff
soi-disant ses bras droit c est donc il
ya le chef d'état du svr le service de
renseignement extérieur qui a pris la
parole et la concept d'égayer et poutine
et ses mots qui publiquement de lui il a
dit qu'est ce que tu me béguin mais me
dit clairement mais dit clairement vous
pouvez le retrouver sur internet si ça
dure une minute et demie 1 ou 2 minutes
avec les sous titres et et le yoga il
savait plus ils en comptent commencer à
trembler encore en plus a tremblé et et
l'autre lui ni mais dites moi clairement
ça c'est un bras droit bah voilà remis
les aciers ça donc il en a pas il y en a
pas mal à personne il ya plus personne